[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
oh so billy comfort remember you talked
about him rip billy conforto right yes
he died in the embankment yeah yeah so
he was a buddy of mine when i was young
you know he was um you know i told you a
little bit he was a bus boy
basically the pride of what is it
lucerne uh from laplace laplace yeah he
was a fighter he's one of america's
first homosexual fire uh not
firefighters fist fighters what yeah so
he could beat anybody's ass dude and
also he was a fight in the in the he was
a professional fighter he was semi-pro i
think like he beat people up like in the
area but you're saying he was the first
homosexual fist fighter by far the
name one
billy that's bailey yeah
openly gay dude who'll beat somebody's
ass bruh uh no they're probably not
yeah i would love to be i think i i
think i would love to be mexican i don't
know if i would love if you would love
to be mexican yeah what do you mean it
just seems like
like um not like incarceration you know
what i'm saying i'm not trying to go
deep deep you know i'm trying to go like
kind of safe
safe mexican you know safe mexican yeah
which is
like kind of um
[Music]
i would say kind of near where the
dodgers play i guess somewhere you know
park yeah yeah brendan shaw was like
really the deep dish hunter is he you
know there's a crocodile hunter if he
were who he would be the deep dish
hunter then when he goes deep on eating
it's wild big [ __ ] guy like that i
bet he can really go deep because
imagine in his hand a piece of pizza
doesn't even like it's like yeah yeah
like a peanut yeah it's like uh lansing
or people would say you know on that do
the hand yeah it's crazy
huge yeah cause he will sometimes text
at night and be like hey you know are
you how are you doing fitness-wise and
[ __ ] and i'm like just
yeah and i'm like that's when i know
he's kind of spiraling oh right now he's
like am i doing enough yeah is my
partner outworking me right now yeah let
me make sure that other people are
suffering right now yeah yeah so i can
feel okay you know yeah that's so funny
those guys all think like that too joe's
like that like if you do something i've
brought i swear to god one time i
brought up the job i was like it's like
three years ago no more maybe like four
i was like yeah i started youtubing
some uh
like uh grilling videos you know like
these like grill master guys oh yeah i
was like yeah so i got this grill and he
was like oh really and like
we had this conversation matt a couple
months later he's like oh i got like
meat thermometers i'm like and then like
he's posting all now he's like a grill
master wow i swear to god it was me
saying like starting it i'm i'm gonna
start grilling stuff and like uh i'm
learning more about it he was like
that's interesting became a grill master
yeah yeah anytime any like super
competitive do you say something he's
like dalia does that yeah dalia does
that i gotta uh yeah what was i doing i
have one like a the snow cone thing or
something and a couple weeks later he's
[ __ ] texting me about him about
[ __ ] snow cones and dry ice and that
kind of [ __ ] like i bought a [ __ ]
thing from my house i got this big i
don't know
somebody gave it to me yeah do anyone
admit he bought it oh right right right
that's that's a big thing that's his
thing too it's like yeah i just it
dropped from the sky yeah have you seen
dumbo drop he's like you know just
there's a snow cone machine in my house
just somebody gave it to me
i think there was some older woman that
i kind of had sex with i think once the
older woman that i kind of had sex with
yeah that's kind of the story of my life
do you like older ladies no but this is
what's the biggest age gap you've ever
had oh i don't know probably um
besides when i came out of my mother
probably yeah i would say
i don't know man maybe
48
so
nine years
that's not that maybe this lady's 48 now
and i'm 39 so maybe
yeah because at some point it's almost
like you're holding a bag of someone and
they're inside of it that's what i don't
like whenever someone's old yeah
you know what i'm talking about though
kinda no but i i mean i like keep going
next time you hug somebody that's old
uh-huh grip them in the back with both
your hands okay okay and like and
they're gonna really hold on and just
kind of they're gonna try to get away a
little right
and that's nature that's human nature
because they'll feel the grip
yeah it just is a human nature when
somebody grabs you from your back you
try you want to
it's an escape thing yeah nature right
yeah so
you're going to feel that and you're
still going to kind of it's almost going
to feel like you put somebody in a
sleeping bag and held onto the bag and
they try to run off and that's how you
feel like sex with older women is like
yeah because
i hate to say that because it's kind of
rude but their skin gets kind of loose
you know what about johnny you look like
you've been with some old broads what's
the oldest you've had that's so true
isn't it
when i was 16 um i hooked up with a 45
year old woman that is
yeah yeah how was it um how was it
pretty crazy yeah yeah what do you mean
you're talking to somebody was molested
brother yeah that was it was it great
yeah it was kind of great at the
beginning and then it got kind of weird
towards the end i had a similar thing
yeah kind of weird towards the end in
court okay that's why i was older than
you but i was still like 20 21 and this
lady was in
her 40s wow
and
it was not good
and it wasn't good why you fell in love
no i was [ __ ] blackout drunk
and
the
i mean i've said this before
on a pot but like when i woke up i woke
up you know you could come out of a
blackout and you're like i don't know
where i am
i was looking out a window just looking
into a backyard and i was like i have
like you know when you i mean you wake
up from a blackout oh yeah i don't know
what i'm looking at right now i was like
it's like flowers for algerian have you
ever read that book no
it's kind of like that a little bit yeah
i think so
thanks he's like that's a good
description it's read it i just feel
like a hand i feel a hand no on my
abdomen
and i'm like
like i look down i'm like what the [ __ ]
i mean because i was that like really
really black outdressed
and then i start you know you start to
have little
little pieces of it come alive yeah
you're like oh and i hear her go like
hey sweetie
like
how are you feeling i'm like what the
[ __ ] and i turn
and i'm not exaggerating i've said this
and it's true it looked like bill
belichick and a wig like it looked like
wow a [ __ ]
kind of
a smoky a man who smokes and works at a
diner or something wow and i was like
holy [ __ ] and she was like i'm gonna
take a shower and i thought i would
thought she's gonna say [ __ ] no i
thought i was like i'll split right now
like and i realize i'm like picking my
clothes up from all over the house and
i'm getting dressed and i realized about
to walk out the door like i don't know
where i am and i also didn't drive here
yeah so i just have to wait in her
kitchen
for her to finish showering i'm looking
at the fridge
it's got report cards no kids it's like
sixth grade and i was like oh [ __ ] man
i don't have a marriage experience yeah
i've been in you know i've had bad sex
with probably with
countless women hundreds we're about to
say hundreds oh yeah
oh yeah
dude nobody's provided more bad sex
across america than your boy right here
really oh
i'll put that up against anybody bro you
know what i'm saying what do you think
do you play the game do you think you
know your number
no i don't you don't but you don't want
to even get into it no i don't i mean i
know it's probably a decent number
it's probably something brendan's shop
couldn't count to let's put it there
but he can't kill that i know he
have you seen his little accountant
thing no oh it's crazy really you know
those things that kids have with the
slider that's how you get a little bitty
one pocket abacus yeah he's like two
three four and he sounds it out
and then one time he ate one of the
things off of it so now he doesn't even
know
that
the 10's really night yeah yeah yeah
yeah
the other day i heard him say carrie the
40. and i'm like he's done
he's done i got to be black in seattle
right that's easy bro right you know
what i'm saying like a good time there
yeah yeah that's [ __ ] for sure but
like houston
yeah i'd be riskier yeah
then you get to like biloxi or something
oh yeah no you get to gary indiana and
then it's
do you remember being a kid and being
like
my god i wish i was black like when when
you
because when you're a kid you know first
you have no idea that p like i remember
my first best friend we were talking
like five years old yeah and it was
black but i didn't make the distinction
that there's a really you know i mean
like you don't right point it out and
then like you turn
i don't know maybe it's like eight or
something and you start having interests
like music
sports and you're like oh we [ __ ]
suck yeah like i'm watching football and
i'm like how come nobody that i like
looks like me yeah you know what i mean
nobody like it was jerry rice yeah and
dion sanders i'm like who the where's
mike and they're like this is the best
guys
michael jordan like no one's us yeah
who's us alice is always a guy like
standing there like this you know like
god certainly the guy that they mock
yeah and make a [ __ ] fool of cross up
and he's like oh and
yeah and you're like that's my that's
they're like that's who you are you're
that guy
or like football i remember watching
college football and it's like
you know you watch all the good games
like acc sec and then and then they're
like you know have you seen the byu
they're having a good year a bunch of
white guys you know it's all slow and
[ __ ] yeah like there's no [ __ ] high
school beating on the tv
like what's going on man there's no punt
returns yeah just like sensible blocking
like four yard average runs like this
[ __ ] sucks some of the players even
have whistles you're like this is
like this seems erroneous yeah there's
no i don't know man i yeah i remember
being like that's what i want to be i
want to be black you ever like watch a
sport an event that you don't care about
but you realize everyone's so excited
you're like i guess i'll watch this oh
yeah i mean i feel like that like during
like the world cup or something you know
i'm like i'll give a [ __ ] about this but
it seems like half the world does so
yeah i'd be like all right let's see
what's going on yeah some guy has his
face painted like with house paint yeah
that's not gonna come out it's gonna be
a while dude you know now they have that
bj's pizza house
that fancy when it's a chain everywhere
yeah yeah yeah this was just a freelance
bj's you know
and a lot of people that worked there
were alcoholics and
um if you're running a pizza parlor it's
you know
it's not strange
yeah to have
some derelicts our most popular item oh
yeah yeah dude we had this one guy
and he was always doing methamphetamines
and all that you know he was on uppers
and [ __ ]
side splitters he was on all of it yeah
he would show you just a big you know
like a open wound he had and [ __ ] he was
[ __ ] up and he um
but he could make pizzas so fast you
know because he was on up was it good
pizza
i thought it was kind of wet in the
middle to me it was wet in the middle
yeah
the crust was a little wet in the middle
the outside yeah was pretty good
yeah thin crust right yeah it got
it definitely got thin in the middle
where it was wet on the outside
pretty strong do you like thin crust i
wouldn't want to sleep in the same bed
as my mom you know
why
i just wouldn't want to i don't think
like i wouldn't mind it for a nap or
something but i'm not staying there all
night
and you don't think a man that's married
to her would want to no because but it's
something about your mom
i think yeah she's just not the kind of
lady i wouldn't lay that into her next
door that long on my eyes closed and
[ __ ] think everything is in a [ __ ]
oh really yeah i could see her
crazy temper no just kind of like you
know making a choice in the middle of
the night that you wake up and feel like
oh this is something maybe you should
have consulted with me on you know
really yes she's just kind of like a go
get it kind of lady well this guy was on
uppers dude i would barely have my pizza
made right my dough out and he would
have his [ __ ] folded into a [ __ ]
like a macho man like a swan you know
like he would have his folded in like
like a sherman tank you know be like he
could just he was so fast with the doe
well he would see through the the matrix
with oh yeah he would like the uppers
would even help him oh he was dude if he
was alive now and they had instagram and
he also might be alive yeah but
if he
if
if there was a way to know if he was
alive or not yeah at a mass scale
he would be a star man because this guy
could i mean he would have a cooking
show or something
do you like the cooking shows i don't
watch any of that yeah that's more for
women i think
okay okay i'm watching somebody [ __ ]
cook while i'm laying there hungry bro
what is this guantanamo bay you can be
fed and watch it yeah but still
it just seems outlandish bro i'm not
that lazy okay i don't know
all right not that lazy i'm gonna watch
somebody putting a recipe together you
know what i'm saying
do you want to see like some high level
chef do some [ __ ] you don't like that
nah i'm like i don't watch but i still
think you know
dude this girl's house i went over to
one time
he had probably
five six dogs dude in a studio apartment
right yeah yeah and she broke out that
cooter bruh and these animals
i mean it was like it was thanksgiving
they all jumped up on the bed you know
and i was like this is
in this and you guys [ __ ] with the
animals on the bed you [ __ ] up we
tried to we did our best she doesn't
even go like go into the animal at first
she kind of like uh put a pillow like in
front of one i'm like
he's still gonna know we're [ __ ] yeah
of course
you know like he's and he could just put
his neck like that like it was a long
animal yeah
so i just didn't get like some of her
but it was crazy man it was almost like
being um
it felt like march of the penguins a
little bit
well i hate i mean so nice when people
bring you things but when you're on the
road and they're like
i have this for you it's a six by four
foot bat carved with your name like yeah
i gotta fly home man yeah and they're
like yeah they don't think about it i'm
like i can't bring this yeah uh if i
don't like it i'll take it because i'm
not
gonna bring it right but if i really
like i'm like will you please ship this
to me dude yeah because i'd like to have
this oh that's nice that's a good that's
a good way to think to do it but ship
ship the thing if you're if it's a big
right like a yeah oh yeah if it's real
big some yeah i'm trying to think of
interesting things it's definitely some
heavy stuff that's been the craziest
thing yeah some guy did a bronze uh bust
he said it was a me
didn't look kind of like a black me kind
of
um which is fine yeah sure and it's uh
but
i wasn't ready
i would go latino before i go black
that's me personally but i was you are
part latino right but i go full i'm
talking about having a pistol being on a
[ __ ] animal's back you know
i'm talking about [ __ ]
drinking aloe vera dude yeah [ __ ]
wagon somewhere
okay
yeah okay yeah for life yeah yeah yeah
what yeah i was told you speak spanish i
speak enough to survive and probably i
speak enough to work in the kitchen oh i
got you the [ __ ] dunkings looks cool
yeah the donkey is cool oh okay that's
right then you're never alone kind of
like if you go into a store no one gives
a [ __ ] if i'm in there yeah you want to
be profiled well i want to be cared
about it's like one of the reasons why i
think i kind of like surgery and stuff
because were you like what that i like
surgery like surgery yeah or like
surgical procedures you know do you like
watch them i mean i've watched some on
the internet but i watch i like going
and being a part of it you like being
present at a surgery yeah on myself or
yeah you're [ __ ] on yourself yeah i
like well first of all i'm not gonna do
my own surgeries you know no you
shouldn't yeah people have oh dude i got
coked up with this girl one time and let
her try to cut something out of my hip
and uh she said she could do like
surgery small surgeries i guess i could
take your appendix out basic [ __ ]
yeah
she was out of her [ __ ] mouth of
course she was
anyone that agreed so did she cut you oh
yeah yeah really cut into this thing on
my hip yeah
it's now it's actually scarred up pretty
bad i'll show you it just you tell me
crazy but now it's gotten in oh [ __ ]
but it looks like a cyst
is it
oh i don't know you're not going to ask
a real doctor
i've had enough of the medical
profession have you ever i went and
watched 13 surgeries in a day once oh my
god so i was like 14 years old
and we had this science project and they
were like what do you want it to be and
i was like you were rich i was like no i
i i want to be a doctor so i was a
freshman in high school i had no idea
obviously what it takes to be a doctor
because you were tall probably i was i
looked like a doctor actually tall beard
dude i was like
i was only like an inch or two shorter
than i am now and like 40 pounds less
when i went to the doctor like to the
hospital to what they were like which
medical school are you in i was like i'm
a freshman in high school so
anyways they set it up and they're like
this kid what's they always thought that
you must be like really smart if you
wanna be a doctor that was a [ __ ]
like 2.0 yeah i just thought like it
sounded cool so then they they go in and
they take me to surgery start at like 6
a.m
through the afternoon and i am like
almost puking in some of these things
they're like we're gonna remove a cyst
from this lady's vagina she's 85. don't
say anything because she's awake she's
only like below the waist we've you know
and it's the so they go in there and
they're like oh there's like a
record-sized cyst come take a look at
this and they poke it it's like shooting
where was this operation desert storm
dude this sounds like the weirdest place
you went to this is the mayo clinic in
jacksonville
so
this is like one of the
prestigious hospitals in the country and
that's correct at the end of the day i
was like i don't want to be a surgeon i
don't want to be a doctor it was it was
rough man having the stomach for all
that [ __ ] is like
[ __ ] i mean i don't i definitely don't
have it yeah yeah i mean i don't pass
out and [ __ ] like that but when you see
a 85 year old [ __ ]
expand it and i was saying
from it not shooting post you're not
like
i'm ready what's what's next
it really takes you down
that's sad i love that the doctor pulled
me aside he's like don't make any
comments i was like like what he's like
yeah like you know look at this old
[ __ ] [ __ ] or something i'm like dude
what like this guy he's 14.
yeah it's like i'm watching surgery then
he gives you like a special sigma kai
handshake yeah
that's crazy i know whatever you met
your wife did you know that like oh this
is going to be my wife or did was it no
because we were we were um
we were both like
new comics right and uh we oh we got a
question right here very related well
taken this is actually gary owen
he doesn't seem as athletic tom i'm a
huge fan brandon paris from georgia here
uh by the way why do you guys never come
to georgia for the love of god at least
go to atlanta
it's a big place people i've been there
so there's tons of fans here
anyways my question is
just out of a long-term relationship
uh we were married i thought she was the
one apparently not
tom when you when you met christina i
know you knew i think for quite a while
before you actually married her how did
you know she was actually the one
that way
i don't make the same mistake even
though my last relationship i wouldn't
say a mistake it happened
hmm i like how he calls a relate his
marriage a relationship because i was in
a relationship that didn't work out my
wife
i was in a relationship with this house
and this lady and this cat
and these future plans how do you no no
um i don't know man i mean like well
people make a wrong decision a lot of
the times now but ultimately you still
just trust your gut on everything right
it's a feeling it's like a feeling i
mean yeah but i think some people's guts
are less calculate well calculated
definitely right did you know though
like did you well you said you were
friends for a while so i was friends for
a while um but did you have a sexual
interest why you guys were friends well
i thought she was attractive obviously
but i wasn't like um
i knew she was dating somebody so yeah i
mean i don't like go like i'm gonna try
to pursue someone in a relationship yeah
you know i mean so
we would just see each other at shows it
was always just like i liked her
friendly cool but i mean
i mean i didn't go like hopefully you
break up soon you know right it's not
like that you didn't have voodoo dolls
or any of that
i got a phone call from a friend of mine
who was like uh
she broke up with her boyfriend so i
just swooped in a friend of yours who
you paid to sit outside of her apartment
yeah
basically yeah east side guy you know
yeah
so oh yeah dude right where i want to
live yeah damn man so those guys yeah
reincarnation they got your back man so
he told me what was that he's like come
on come on over now player so
yeah i swooped in
yeah i was thinking whenever i was over
you guys's podcast that
like
nothing ever happened between me and
your wife you know that right i mean
yeah
because i felt like i said that there
and you didn't believe me i did not not
believe you okay yeah
[Music]
just the wrong way
[Music]